Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. O death, rock me asleep, bring me the quiet rest. Let pass my weary, guiltless ghost out of my careful breast. These lines are attributed to Anne Boleyn. She supposedly wrote them in 1536 in the Tower of London as she was awaiting execution at the hands of a French swordsman who had been brought over specially for the purpose by her erstwhile husband, King Henry VIII,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入我们。网址是 therestishistory.com。“哦，死亡，请让我安睡，带给我宁静的休憩。让疲惫、无辜的灵魂，离开我忧虑的胸膛。”这些诗句被认为出自安妮·博林之手。据称她在1536年被关押在伦敦塔时写下了这些诗，当时她正等待着死于一名法国刽子手之手，而这名刽子手是由她曾经的丈夫亨利八世国王专门从法国请来的，
whose marital history has inspired another poem, Divorced, Beheaded, Died, Divorced, Beheaded, died divorced, beheaded, survived and Dominic Sandbrook with me probably the most famous the most famously disastrous sequence of marriages in English history in English history, in world history probably the whole of history definitely
他的婚姻史启发了另一首诗：离婚、斩首、死亡，离婚、斩首、死亡，离婚、斩首、幸存。多米尼克·桑德布鲁克和我在一起，这可能是英国历史上、乃至世界历史上、绝对是整个人类历史上最著名、最灾难性的婚姻序列了。
it's an irresistible subject isn't it it's the stuff of soap operas it's the stuff of costume dramas um it's the stuff of about a thousand channel five documentaries well it's amazing i mean you know we're so we're well into the 70s i think we've done over 70 episodes it's kind of extraordinary that we haven't haven't really done one before yeah we've shown herculean self-restraint i think i guess if if we were you know if we were a tv company we'd have done six on the already if we would actually the reason why we have delayed it doing the six wives of henry the eighth obviously there have been many many great scholars over the years who have written about the reign of henry the eighth one thinks of sir jeffrey J.G. Scarrisbrick, David Starkey but these scholars have now been
这是一个让人无法抗拒的主题，不是吗？这简直是肥皂剧的题材，是古装剧的题材，嗯，大概有一千部第五频道的纪录片都是关于这个的。真的太惊人了，我是说，我们已经讲到了70多集，我想我们已经做了70多集了，居然之前都没有真正做过一期，这真是挺不可思议的。对，我想我们展现了海格力斯般的自制力。我猜如果我们是一家电视公司，我们可能已经拍了六季关于这个内容的了。实际上，我们之所以一直拖延没有讲亨利八世的六个妻子，显然是因为多年来有许多许多伟大的学者写过关于亨利八世统治时期的著作，人们会想到杰弗里·埃尔顿爵士、J.G.斯卡里斯布里克、大卫·斯塔基，但现在这些学者加入了一位新面孔，
joined by a new kid on the block Dominic Sandbrook. Dominic your book The Six Wives of Henry VIII. Tom I don't like the slightly ironic way in which you're... No but to explain this is this is written for children. and absolutely fabulous i read it last night and i'm not in any way just saying that i hugely enjoyed it um and i guess so your other book is on the second world war henry henry the eighth and second world war those are the two big topics but henry the eighth really i mean it's a it's a timeless classic isn't it it is and actually i was always a bit suspicious of it i was never a great aficionado of the Tudors or of the Six Wives of Hymn of the Eighth. I was slightly bridled at the sort of,
多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。多米尼克，你的新书《亨利八世的六个妻子》。汤姆，我不太喜欢你这种略带讽刺的语气……不，但这需要解释一下，这本书是为儿童写的。而且真的棒极了，我昨晚读了，我绝不是在随口说说，我真的非常喜欢它。嗯，我猜你的另一本书是关于第二次世界大战的，亨利八世和第二次世界大战，这是两个宏大的主题，但亨利八世真的——这是一个永恒的经典，不是吗？确实是这样。其实我以前对它一直有点怀疑，我从来不是都铎王朝或亨利八世六位王后的超级狂热粉。我对那种……
oh, I don't know, the sort of soap opera-y nature of it. But then when I started getting into it, I actually found it irresistible. And it's partly the court politics and the sort of Game of Thrones style kind of bed-hopping shenanigans and all that stuff. But the fact is it happens at an absolute hinge moment of history
哦，我不知道，对那种肥皂剧般的性质感到有点抗拒。但当我真正深入其中时，我发现它简直让人无法抗拒。部分原因在于宫廷政治以及那种《权力的游戏》风格的乱搞男女关系和各种破事。但事实是，它发生在历史的一个绝对转折点上，
against the backdrop of these colossal religious changes, which mean that this is without question the biggest political and cultural break in England's history. And it's all snarled up with Anne Bovil and sex appeal exactly henry's lust so the weird thing is that that all these things that it's very easy to dismiss as froth and gossip and the stuff of kind of some tudor tackler they really matter they change the lives of millions of people and that's what makes it so enduringly fascinating well i i remember i um the first time i went to the loire must have been I don't know 20 or something
背景是这些巨大的宗教变革，这意味着毫无疑问，这是英国历史上最大的一次政治和文化断层。这一切都和安妮·博林以及她的性感魅力纠缠在一起，完全就是亨利的好色。所以奇怪的是，所有这些很容易被当作泡沫、八卦以及某种都铎王朝小商品的东西，其实都至关重要。它们改变了数百万人的生活，这正是它经久不衰、令人着迷的原因。我记得我……我第一次去卢瓦尔河谷时，大概是，我不知道，20岁左右吧，
um and visiting all these kind of incredible chateaus that had been built by Henry VIII's exact contemporary François Premier Francis I of France who was king of you know a much more much richer in many ways much more sophisticated country than England um and I felt kind of quite intimidated looking at these glories to Gallic civilization but then I thought yeah but how many wives did Francis I have Henry VIII is a much much better character yeah and I felt a kind of patriotic glow oh that's good to hear that's very good to hear well well Francis I mean Henry did measure himself against Francis I of France And he also measured himself against... So there are basically three big kings, aren't there, at this point?
嗯，参观了所有这些不可思议的城堡，它们是由亨利八世的同代人法兰西一世建造的——也就是法国国王，在很多方面，他统治的国家比英国要得多、要富有得多，也 sophisticated（成熟精致）得多。我看着这些高卢文明的辉煌成就，感到相当敬畏，但随后我想：“是的，但是法兰西一世有几个妻子呢？亨利八世是一个好得多、好得多的角色。”是的，我感到了一股爱国主义的暖流。哦，很高兴听到这个，这太棒了。法兰西一世……我的意思是，亨利确实拿自己和法国的法兰西一世做比较。他也拿自己和……所以这个时候基本上有三个大国王，对吧？
Well, there are two big kings, aren't there? Well, there are two big kings and one kind of... And Henry kind of tried to join the clans. That's right. So there's Francis, or François, and then there's Charles, or Carlos V of Spain, who is also the ruler of the Holy Roman Empire, is just unbelievably rich and has this massive dominion.
嗯，其实有两个大国王，对吧？嗯，有两个大国王，还有一个有点……而亨利则试图挤进这个圈子。没错。所以有法兰西斯，或者说弗朗索瓦，然后有查理，也就是西班牙的卡洛斯五世，他同时也是神圣罗马帝国的统治者，简直富得流油，拥有庞大的领地。
You know, he's got South America and he's, I mean, he is by far the most potent monarch of the day. And poor old Henry, you know, he just rules England and he's desperate. He's absolutely desperate to be taken seriously by these two guys. And he's changing his wives all the time. And there's this sort of farcical, comical element element to him as well as the sort of terrifying and more sinister element well he yeah i mean i i i think he only seems comical if he does seem comical and of course
你知道的，他拥有南美洲，我的意思是，他绝对是当时最有权势的君主。而可怜的亨利，你知道的，他只统治英格兰，他极其渴望——极其渴望被这两个家伙认真对待。他不断地更换妻子。他身上既有这种荒诞、滑稽的成分，也有那种可怕、更显阴暗的成分。好吧，他……我的意思是，我觉得他只有在某种程度上才显得滑稽，当然，
he was played by sid james in the carry-on film so i guess there is a slight element of the comic but but up close i mean he's, he's a very frightening figure. And the fact that he is actually able to go toe-to-toe with the great kings on the continent, I think are a kind of measure of the swagger and the power and the charisma that he does have. And that even non-English people experience. I mean, he's a very, very intimidating.
他在《滑稽戏》电影里是由西德·詹姆士扮演的，所以我想确实有一点喜剧色彩。但近距离来看，他其实是一个非常吓人的形象。他居然能够与欧洲大陆的伟大君主们正面交锋，我认为这正是他身上那种傲气、权力和个人魅力的体现，甚至连非英国人也能感受到这一点。我的意思是，他是一个非常、非常令人畏惧的人。
But you don't get Henry right, I think, unless you emphasise exactly what you just said about his charisma so when he becomes king i mean he's a very impressive person he plays tennis he writes music he writes songs he speaks physically impressive isn't he i mean he's very very good looking he's very muscular very large handsome i mean everybody says he's handsome he looks like a king and and he actually behaves he he plays the part of a king very well i mean that's one thing i think that sometimes people forget is that actually to people at the time what strikes them is not oh he's a complete monster and he's so fat and all this sort of stuff what strikes them is he looks and behaves exactly
但如果你不强调刚刚提到的关于他个人魅力的特质，你就无法真正理解亨利。所以当他成为国王时，他是一个非常令人印象深刻的人。他打网球，他写音乐，他写歌，他说话……他的身体非常健壮，不是吗？他长得非常非常帅，肌肉发达，身材魁梧，英俊潇洒。所有人都说他很帅，他看起来就像个国王。而且他的行为举止——他把国王这个角色扮演得非常好。这是人们有时会忘记的一点：对于当时的人来说，打动他们的并不是“哦，他是个彻头彻尾的怪物，他太胖了”之类的话，打动他们的是，他的外表和行为举止完全
as a king should and if he is sometimes cruel and capricious i think to a lot of people in the 16th century those things were sort of perhaps slightly lamentable but they were better than being weak and dithery and pious and sort of a bit sanctimonious and waffly like henry the sixth for example always praying when he should have been killing people right they like a strong ruler and and and the context for henry's reign is exactly the wars of the roses where henry the sixth of lancaster is so useless that he ends up kind of being deposed twice basically yes by one of yeah and then you've you've got well actually you begin your book with with bosworth don't you with with um yeah because i think that's really important to understand his context. So that he, first of all, he doesn't know he's early modern rather than late medieval. You know, he, at the back of his mind are the Wars of the Roses.
符合一个国王应有的样子。如果他有时显得残忍和反复无常，我想对于16世纪的许多人来说，这些行为或许有些令人惋惜，但总比软弱、优柔寡断、假仁假义、唠唠叨叨要好，比如亨利六世那样——本该杀伐决断的时候却总是在祈祷。没错，他们喜欢强势的统治者。而亨利统治时期的背景正是玫瑰战争，当时兰开斯特家族的亨利六世是如此无能，以至于他最终基本上被废黜了两次，没错，是被其中一位……然后你还有……其实你的书是以博斯沃思战役开篇的，对吧？通过……是的，因为我认为理解他的背景非常重要。这样一来，首先，他并不觉得自己属于近代早期而不是中世纪晚期。你知道的，在他的潜意识里，挥之不去的是玫瑰战争。
And secondly, he doesn't know that the Wars of the Roses are over. So we conventionally say, well, they ended in 1485 when his father, a Welsh adventurer from a little branch of the family, basically is the last man standing after this great Game of Thrones style bloodbath but Henry VIII doesn't know that that's all over I mean neither of the two Henry's do for them they think there could be a revolt at any moment that the old kind of guard the old nobility could be plotting against them which actually frankly a lot of the time they are um so they there's that sort of insecurity and that fear, and that lies behind this whole business of the son.
其次，他并不知道玫瑰战争已经结束了。所以我们通常会说，嗯，战争结束于1485年，当时他的父亲——一个来自家族小分支的威尔士冒险家，在经历了一场《权力的游戏》风格的大屠杀后，成为了笑到最后的幸存者。但亨利八世并不知道这一切都结束了。我的意思是，两个亨利都不知道。对他们来说，他们觉得随时都可能发生叛乱，老近卫军、老贵族可能正在密谋反对他们——坦白说，很多时候他们确实在密谋。所以，那种不安全感和恐惧感，正是关于子嗣这一整个问题的根源所在。
He has to have an heir, because he knows if I don't have an heir, then basically everything my dad and I have done will be for nothing, and those bastards will get the throne back again. And that's at the back of his mind the whole time. That fear, you know, that people are... This stuff about him being paranoid which you often read oh henry was paranoid he was like stalin or whatever i mean he's only paranoid in the sense that he takes it a little bit further than you or i might have done
他必须有一个继承人，因为他知道，如果我没有继承人，那么我和我父亲所做的一切都将化为乌有，那些混蛋会把王位重新夺回去。这种恐惧一直盘旋在他的脑海里。这种恐惧，你知道的，人们总说他有被迫害妄想症，你经常会读到“哦，亨利有被害妄想症，他就像斯大林一样”之类的话。我的意思是，他所谓的妄想，只是比你我可能做出的程度稍微过头了一点而已，
but frankly he lives at a time when if you don't kill people first they probably will kill you although i mean fair enough but if you're marrying him i mean well yes i suppose it's definitely a consideration to bear in mind isn't it and also i suppose the other consideration to bear in mind as he gets older is that he gets fatter and fatter uh and less attractive and he starts to get smelly pus ridden ulcers all up his legs uh and ultimately he ends up so fat does he not dominic yeah that he has he has to have enemas he does the enemas you may conceivably mention in your book i know you love this detail about the enemas um basically anyone who ever encounters my book thinks this is the either the best thing or the only or the least worst thing in it which is this description of how
但坦白说，他生活的那个时代，如果你不先杀了别人，别人很可能会先杀了你。话虽如此，如果你要嫁给他，嗯，好吧，这绝对是一个需要考虑的因素，不是吗？而且我想，随着他年龄的增长，另一个需要考虑的因素是，他变得越来越胖、越来越没有吸引力，他的腿上开始长出流脓、散发恶臭的溃疡。最终，多米尼克，他胖到了一种程度，不是吗？以至于他必须接受灌肠。他确实要灌肠，你可能在你的书中提到了这一点。我知道你很喜欢关于灌肠的这个细节。基本上，所有读过我书的人都认为这是书中最好的一点，或者是唯一好的一点，或者是没那么糟的一点，那就是关于
henry's doctors would push this grease tube up his bottom, which was then attached to, I think it's kind of a metal tube, and it's attached to a pig's bladder that's filled with honey and milk and herbs and stuff, and they squirt this. I mean, imagine being the person who does the squirting. They squirt this. This is the kind of top historical analysis that I'm afraid you just don't get with Sir Geoffrey Elton. I was about to say, does Geoffrey Elton go in for the list i mean maybe he does i don't know no no david stargay dreary stuff about parliament i'm sure david stargay goes in for all this yeah antonio fraser
亨利的医生如何把一根涂了油脂的管子塞进他的屁股，这根管子连着，我想是一种金属管，连着一个装满了蜂蜜、牛奶和草药等东西的猪膀胱，然后他们把这些东西喷射进去。我的意思是，想象一下负责喷射的那个人。他们把这个喷进去。这就是恐怕你在杰弗里·埃尔顿爵士那里绝对看不到的顶级历史分析。我正想说，杰弗里·埃尔顿会写这些吗？也许会吧，我不知道。不，不，大卫·斯塔基只写那些关于议会的乏味东西。我确信大卫·斯塔基会写进这些内容的。安东尼娅·弗雷泽……
um but yeah i mean it doesn't make him any more even-tempered i think and probably for the wives certainly towards the end of the reign this is a kind of slightly unpleasant aspect of marital relations so the first the first catherine of aragon yeah who is the she is the aunt of um charles v that she is the emperor the king of spain um and she herself is the daughter of um ferdinand and isabella who are the kind of the great dual monarchs castile and aragon who um usher spain into her golden age so 1492 they capture granada which is the last kind of muslim outpost complete the the rey conquista they uh expel the jews from spain and they serve as patrons for uh columbus's discovery of the new world. Yeah, exactly. So they're heavyweights.
但是，是的，这并没有让他变得性格温和一些，对于他的王后们来说，尤其是在统治后期，这确实是婚姻生活中一个稍微有点让人不愉快的方面。所以第一位，阿拉贡的凯瑟琳，是的，她是查理五世的姑姑，也就是皇帝、西班牙国王的姑姑。她本人是斐迪南和伊莎贝拉的女儿，这两位是卡斯蒂利亚和阿拉贡伟大的双君主，他们引领西班牙走向了黄金时代。1492年，他们攻克了格拉纳达——这是最后一个穆斯林据点，完成了收复失地运动。他们将犹太人驱逐出西班牙，并资助了哥伦布对新大陆的发现。是的，绝对的。所以他们是重量级人物。
Yeah, that happened when she's seven. I mean, she's born in 1485. But in that sense, I mean, it's quite a coup for Henry VII, who's, you know, a bit of a parvenu, a usurper king of a rather marginal kingdom, to bag their youngest daughter, who I think is Ferdinand's favourite. Yes, that's right. that's actually absolutely right and i think it is a bit of a coup for him um the english are delighted with the match so he lines this up for his eldest son who's called arthur who ends up not becoming
是的，她七岁时就发生了这件事。我的意思是，她出生于1485年。但从这个意义上说，对于亨利七世这样一个有点暴发户色彩、统治着一个边缘王国的篡位国王来说，能把他们的小女儿——据说是斐迪南最疼爱的女儿——娶到手，确实是一次相当大的政变。是的，没错，这确实完全正确。我认为这对他是次不小的政变。英国人对这门婚事欣喜若狂。所以他把这门婚事安排给了他的长子亚瑟，而亚瑟最终并没有成为
king because he dies um so catherine of aragon is quite a catch and the reason i think that they both want the marriage is because they they're both anti-french such a theme of apocos actually loathing of the french so the french are the by you know incredibly powerful very rich country ginormous army um they're obviously a rival to the newly united castile and aragon so it makes sense to ally with the country on the other side the country to the north which is england i mean england is you know it doesn't have a great reputation it is war-torn rainy kind of miserable not not colossally rich um but it it kind of works as an alliance and so poor katherine of aragon as a teenager is basically shipped off to a country that she's never been to she doesn't speak the
国王，因为他英年早逝了。所以阿拉贡的凯瑟琳算是一个相当了不起的成。而我认为他们双方都想要这桩婚事的原因在于，他们都反法。这也是我们播客的一个主题：对法国人的极度厌恶。法国人是一个极其强大、非常富有、拥有庞大军队的国家，他们显然是刚刚统一的卡斯蒂利亚和阿拉贡的竞争对手。因此，与海峡对岸的国家、北方的国家——也就是英格兰结盟，是顺理成章的。我的意思是，英格兰……你知道的，它的名声并不算太好，饱受战争蹂躏，多雨，有些凄凉，并不算富可敌国。但作为一种同盟关系，它确实起作用了。所以可怜的阿拉贡的凯瑟琳在十几岁的时候，就被送往一个她从未去过、甚至不会说
language well and this kind of amazing advice that she gets from um henry the seventh's wife elizabeth of york what she should do to get get ready for life in england is that she should learn to drink wine because the water is so horrible and poisonous and she should learn to speak french which is odd that is weird because yes because elizabeth york says no one here speaks spanish so don't come here with your your your lisping ways you know you're gonna have to speak something else so why don't you have to french but it doesn't occur to anybody english is just such a kind of um de classe language yeah english what's the point of learning it even if you're going to england yeah in france french is
当地语言的国家。她从亨利七世的妻子约克的伊丽莎白那里得到了极其惊人的建议——关于她应该如何准备在英格兰的生活：她应该学会喝酒，因为这里的水太糟糕、太有毒了；她还应该学会说法语。这很奇怪，确实很奇怪。因为约克的伊丽莎白说：“这里没有人说西班牙语，所以别带着你那口齿不清的腔调来这里，你得说点别的。所以你为什么不学法语呢？”但这并没有进入任何人的脑海——英语只是一种非常低级（déclassé）的语言。英语，哪怕你是去英格兰，去学它又有什么意义呢？在法国，法语是
the language of romance and chivalry and and and high culture so i suppose that makes sense it is kind of weird that she pitches up without a word of i mean she basically doesn't even have the burlitz phrasebook um um and it goes very well doesn't it she she marries um arthur it's all very glamorous wedding in st paul's yeah it goes that's all a great and she's a great hit actually with the crowds. I mean, the one thing about Catherine of Aragon that people really get wrong is we always see her, the sort of late period,
浪漫、骑士精神和高级文化的语言，所以我想这倒也说得过去。但她抵达时一句英语也不会说，这确实有点奇怪。我的意思是，她基本上连百灵果语言书都没带。而且这一切进展得非常顺利，不是吗？她嫁给了亚瑟，在圣保罗大教堂举行了一场非常迷人的婚礼。是的，一切都非常成功，而且她实际上深得民众喜爱。关于阿拉贡的凯瑟琳，人们真正搞错的一点是，我们总是把她看作是后期的那个样子——
a bit like as we do with Henry VIII. We see them at the end rather than the beginning. At the beginning, she's a teenager. She's pretty. She's quite short. She doesn't look especially Spanish. She's got kind of fair reddish hair. People do say she's got a very fair reddish hair um people do say
这有点像我们对待亨利八世一样。我们看到的是他们的晚年，而不是他们的早年。在最初的时候，她只是个十几岁的少女。她很漂亮。她个子相当矮。她看起来并不怎么像西班牙人。她长着一头金红色的头发。人们确实说她有一头非常金红色的头发……人们确实说
she's got a very deep voice and a sort of very heavily accented but you know she's she's so young tom she's in her mid-teens she's just say goodbye to her parents i mean it really is the kind of trajectory of a children's story the girl separated from her family who goes away to this weird country um and she acquits herself at first brilliantly you know she marries arthur off they go to ludlow castle in the marches kind of arthurian legend yeah i mean it is she's living at that point she is living a fairy tale she's gone off to be camelot she's very popular she's gone to a camelot the the fire burns in the hearth they're drinking cups of kind of warmed goblets of warmed wine and then disastrously after a few months when they've been very happy
她的声音非常低沉，而且带有非常重的口音。但你知道的，她太年轻了，汤姆。她当时才十五六岁，刚刚向父母告别。这真的就像是一个童话故事的轨迹：女孩离开家人，前往一个陌生的国家。一开始，她表现得极其出色。你知道的，她嫁给了亚瑟，他们去了边境地区的勒德洛城堡——那里充满了亚瑟王的传奇色彩。是的，我的意思是，在那段时间里，她过着童话般的生活。她去了卡米洛特（亚瑟王的城堡），她非常受欢迎。他们去了卡米洛特，壁炉里的火焰熊熊燃烧，他们端着一杯杯温热的、斟满温酒的高脚杯。然后，灾难降临了。几个月后，当他们正沉浸在幸福中时，
arthur drops dead of the sweating sickness and then she has this terrible time she comes back to london and basically no one really wants anything to do with her but she can't go back to spain the spanish don't want her back henry doesn't want to send her back he sort of keeps her as a it's not doesn't have any money does he yeah she's got no money she's quite exactly because he's just piling up taxes in his coffers um so she's she actually clearly goes into a very deep depression she's i mean think about it she's a girl in her late teens and then early 20s she doesn't speak the language she has very few friends most of her servants who've come with her go back to Spain
亚瑟染上了出汗病突然暴毙。接着她经历了可怕的时光。她回到伦敦，基本上没有人真的想跟她扯上关系。但她又回不了西班牙，西班牙人也不要她回去。亨利不想把她送回去，于是就把她当成……她其实也没有钱，对吧？是的，她身无分文。完全是因为亨利正把税收堆满自己的金库。所以她显然陷入了极度的抑郁之中。我的意思是，想想看，她是一个十几岁到二十出头的女孩，语言不通，几乎没有朋友，随她一起来的大多数仆人都回了西班牙，
she has been cut off from her family her husband um her teenage husband is dead um she spends all her time praying and she basically starts writing letters she writes letters to her father to the pope and so on um And they write back. I mean, at one point the Pope basically writes to her and says, you've got to start eating. So it's clear that she's starving herself or got some kind of eating disorder. And there's people who are really worried about her. And so she's sort of sunk in this utter misery for years.
她与家人断绝了联系，她的丈夫——那个十几岁的丈夫也去世了。她把所有的时间都花在祈祷上，并且基本上开始写信。她给她的父亲写信，给教皇写信等等。他们也回信了。我的意思是，有一次教皇甚至写信给她，说：“你必须开始吃东西了。”这显然说明她在绝食，或者得了某种进食障碍。有人真的很为她担心。因此，她在这种彻底的痛苦中沉沦了好几年。
But then her handsome prince, her second handsome prince, comes to the rescue. But that's exactly what happened. So she'd met Henry at the wedding, and he'd been leaping around like a lunatic. Taking his shirt off. Taking his shirt off and dancing inappropriately or whatever, and everyone thought it was very funny. He's the sort of classic younger brother, you know,
但随后，她的白马王子，她的第二位白马王子前来拯救她了。这正是发生的事情。所以她曾在婚礼上见过亨利，当时他像个疯子一样跳来跳去。脱掉衬衫。脱掉衬衫，跳着不得体的舞蹈之类的，每个人都觉得这非常有趣。他就是那种典型的弟弟，你知道的，
who kind of, he's the James Holland. Well, he's literally Prince Harry. Yes, he is literally Prince Harryry except without the the compassion and kindness um so his early period prince harry i think it's better he's yeah he's he's this sort of japester um he becomes king 1509 uh he is i think he's um about to turn 18 or so so he's young he's very handsome very accomplished and he decides straight away i must have a wife and as luck would have it there's one there's there's a perfect candidate waiting right there in in london his brother's widow um now the question, even at that stage, there's the question about,
可以说，他就像是詹姆斯·霍兰。好吧，他简直就是哈里王子。是的，他真的就是哈里王子，只不过没有那种同情心和善良，呃，所以他是早期版本的哈里王子，我觉得这样更好，他就是那种爱恶作剧的人。他于1509年登基，呃，我想他当时大概快18岁左右，所以他很年轻，非常英俊，才华横溢，他立刻决定：我必须得娶个妻。而真巧，伦敦正好有一个完美的人选在等着他，也就是他哥哥的遗孀。嗯，问题是，即使在那个阶段，也有这样一个问题：
is it really legit to marry your brother's widow? Because there's a bit of the Bible that says, don't do it. But there's another bit of the Bible that says, you really ought to marry your brother's widow. So they get a dispensation from the Pope. The Pope basically says, it's absolutely fine. Go for it. They get married.
娶你哥哥的遗孀真的合法吗？因为《圣经》里有一段说，不要这么做。但《圣经》里还有另一段说，你实在应该娶你哥哥的遗孀。于是他们从教皇那里得到了特许。教皇基本上说，完全没问题。去吧。他们结婚了。
And Catherine is living the life of Riley. you know she's she's emerged from her depression she's she's deeply in love with her husband he seems deeply in love with her they're very happy they're having tournaments they're having these ridiculous masks where he at court where he dresses up as kind of robin hood or something comes in with his mates, and bursts into a bedchamber. I mean, you can just picture the scene. Bloody good bloke. Yeah. We had a great laugh.
凯瑟琳过着神仙般的生活。你知道的，她已经走出了抑郁，她深深地爱着她的丈夫，他似乎也深深地爱着她，他们非常幸福，他们举办比武大会，他们在宫廷里举行那些荒唐的假面舞会，他在会上打扮成罗宾汉之类的人物，和他的伙伴们一起冲进卧室。我的意思是，你完全能想象那个场景。真是个好家伙。是的。我们玩得真开心。
We had a really good laugh. We all dressed up as the... Yeah, okay. I mean, you can absolutely... This is why Damien Lewis was perfect. Because you can absolutely see all these kind of old harrovians or something like i mean prince harry is completely the model they're bursting in they're all dressed up as the merry men in kind of colored hoods or something and then the catherine and the girls say oh gosh i didn't recognize you come for a kiss
我们玩得真高兴。我们都打扮成……是的，好吧。我的意思是，你绝对可以……这就是为什么达米安·刘易斯是完美人选。因为你完全能看出所有这些哈罗公学的老毕业生或者什么人，我的意思是哈里王子完全就是这个原型，他们冲进来，都打扮成穿着彩色斗篷之类的绿林好汉，然后凯瑟琳和姑娘们说：‘哦天哪，我没认出你来，来亲一个。’
and all this i mean they think it's there... They think this is the height of... And also, when Henry goes off to attack the French, which he's always doing, she helps to guard the northern frontier against the weasel Scott. She does. The Scots attack us. And the Battle of Flodden, disastrous defeat for the Scots.
诸如此类。我的意思是，他们觉得这……他们觉得这简直是……而且，每当亨利出发去攻打法国时——他总是这么干——她都会帮忙保卫北部边境，抵抗那些狡猾的苏格兰人。她确实这么做了。苏格兰人进攻我们。弗洛登战役，苏格兰人遭遇惨败。
So she's doing well. But, of course, there's one drawback. She gives Henry a daughter, Mary, but no son. and as you said this is a a catastrophic failure yeah of course i mean it's a failure i mean it's incredibly harsh that's exactly how that's how it's seen how it's perceived you're right you're you're dead right that is how it's judged um it's very harsh and of course the failure is seen as hers rather than henry's exactly exactly they do have a son um henry uh but he dies very young um only after i think actually dominic having said that having said that the failure is hers of course actually henry does come to think the failure might be his as
所以她干得不错。但是，当然，有一个缺点。她给亨利生了个女儿玛丽，却没有生儿子。正如你所说，这是一次灾难性的失败。是的，当然，我的意思是这是一次失败，我的意思是这极其残酷，情况就是这样，人们就是这么看的，你说得对，你完全说得对，人们就是这样评判它的。这非常残酷。当然，这次失败被认为是她的责任，而不是亨利的。完全如此，完全如此。他们的确生了一个儿子，亨利，但他夭折了。其实多米尼克，话虽如此，尽管失败是她的责任，但实际上亨利后来也开始觉得失败可能也有他的一份，
well doesn't he because he comes to see it as being the judgment of god he does and what's clear is that you get to the 1520s everything seems to be fine henry has been king for more than 10 years he's secure he's very handsome everybody's very impressed with him you know he he cuts a just a generally very impressive if slightly scary figure um but what clearly happens by the 1520s is she's a bit older than he is so there's partly that classic kind of psychological thing of the the husband with the with the older wife and he's you know there's an element of a sort of i don't know would you call it a midlife crisis he kind of fancies a younger model um but also the son thing is is is clearly she has got used to it whereas it is weighing on his mind
不是吗？因为他开始认为这是上帝的审判。他的确这么想。很明显的是，到了1520年代，一切似乎都很好。亨利当国王已经超过10年了，他的地位稳固，非常英俊，每个人都对他的印象极其深刻。你知道，他总的来说给人一种非常深刻但又略显可怕的印象。但到了1520年代，明显发生的情况是：她比他大一些，所以部分原因在于那种经典的心理现象，即丈夫配一个年长的妻子，他呢——这其中有一种类似于——我不知道，你会称之为中年危机吗？他有点看上年轻的了。但同时，生儿子的事显然是她已经习以为常了，而这却一直压在他的心头。
okay so the younger model yeah probably i mean probably the most famous of henry's wives i would say yeah i think so so and berlin and seen as the most romantic weirdly in my mind and and she didn't need to be told to learn french because she'd spent most of her life in France. So she's the daughter of one of Henry's most trusted diplomats. Sir Thomas Pym. And she is kind of laden waiting to the Queen of France. And she comes back to England and she's fashionable in the way that someone who spent lots of time in France is. She's not, I mean, she's not a sensational beauty, is she?
好吧，年轻的款，是的，可能吧。我的意思是，可能是亨利的所有妻子中最著名的一位，我会这么说。是的，我也这么觉得。安妮·博林，在我的印象中，她被视为最浪漫的一个，真奇怪。而且她不需要别人告诉她去学法语，因为她大半生都在法国度过。所以她是亨利最信任的外交官之一的女儿，托马斯·佩姆爵士。她是法国王后的侍女。她回到英国，带着那种在法国待了很久的人才有的时尚感。她其实并不是，我的意思是，她并不是一个轰动的美人，对吧？
No, she's not. I mean, that's one of the things that people... She has a sixth finger. Well, I'm not sure. I think the sixth finger is... There's a lot of details about Anne Boleyn. And the third nipple is definitely not true. That's Scaramanga from The Man with the Golden Gum.
不，她不是。我的意思是，这是人们……她有六根手指。嗯，我不确定。我觉得六根手指是……关于安妮·博林有很多细节。第三个乳头绝对不是真的。那是《金枪人》里的斯卡拉曼加。
No, no, I'm not confusing it. Very rarely Christopher Lee. She, yes, people say she has sallow skin and she kind of, a very thin face and she's dark and, you know, people sort of disapprove of her looks. But people at court say she is very witty and she's clever and she's sharp and she's kind of charming and if you like that kind of thing and and she clearly represents to henry just the
不，不，我没搞混。极少数情况下是克里斯托弗·李。她，是的，人们说她皮肤蜡黄，脸很瘦，肤色较深，你知道的，人们有点不赞成她的长姿。但宫廷里的人说她非常机智、聪明、敏锐、迷人，如果你喜欢那种类型的话。而且她显然代表了亨利心中的……
complete antithesis of catherine who is so dutiful and serious and and is turning more and more to god and basically spending a lot of time praying although ann is also very religious but inclining towards this kind of radical new understanding of christianity that will come to be called protestantism that's right she's read books in france she's read like french translations of the bible and things so she's full of all this stuff and i think to henry all of this is kind of intoxicating megan quality perhaps yeah i think that's not a bad coming yeah coming from another country bringing a kind of radical exciting dramatic new way of understanding things and and it also really suits henry by the way this new way because the new way makes him more powerful because obviously the pope is colossally powerful and the new way basically involves
与凯瑟琳的完全对立面。凯瑟琳是如此恭顺、严肃，而且越来越转向上帝，花大量时间祈祷（尽管安妮其实也很虔诚，但她倾向于那种被称为新教的、激进的新基督教理解）。没错，她在法国读过书，读过诸如法语版《圣经》之类的东西，所以她满脑子都是这些东西。我想对亨利来说，所有这些都带有一种令人陶醉的魅力，也许吧。是的，我觉得这种说法不错，来自另一个国家，带来了一种激进、令人兴奋、戏剧化的全新理解方式。这种新方式对亨利来说也非常合适，因为新方式使他变得更有权势。显然，教皇拥有巨大的权力，而新方式基本上涉及...
saying oh the pope doesn't really have power over you you know she's basically giving her amberlin is giving henry all these pamphlets by william tyndale and simon fish and these kind of reformation theologians which conveniently for him say oh the pope has no jurisdiction in your kingdom at all you can do what you like so from his point of view it's kind of win-win pile in yes so so he does he decides he wants to divorce catherine and decides he wants to do it because of the biblical injunction against brothers marrying their brothers' wives. But Tom, that's just not a decision that we should just dismiss lightly.
声称“哦，教皇对你其实没有什么权力”。你知道，她基本上给了亨利——安妮·博林给了亨利许多威廉·廷代尔和西蒙·菲什等宗教改革神学家的册子，这些册子对亨利来说非常方便地说：“哦，教皇对你的王国根本没有司法管辖权，你想干嘛就干嘛。”所以从他的角度来看，这算是一种双赢，大举介入吧。是的，所以他决定他想和凯瑟琳离婚，并决定因为《圣经》中禁止兄弟娶兄弟妻子的禁令而这么做。但是，汤姆，这可不是我们能轻率否决的决定。
I'm not. I'm not. That is a colossal... Are you saying that I'm downplaying the significance of biblical injunction? For once, yeah. Heaven forbid. The shame of it. No, of course.
我没有。我没有。这是一个巨大的……你是说我在淡化《圣经》禁令的重要性吗？难得一次，是的。上帝保佑。真丢脸。不，当然。
I mean, it's incredibly important. But it's also the fact that Anne, this is Anne's extraordinary role in history, actually. Kings had had mistresses since time immemorial. Henry had had mistresses, including anne's sister mary and is and the really remarkable thing is that anne says i will not be your mistress i must be your wife does that mean and obviously this is not a detail that you went into in your children's book yeah does that mean that henry does not sleep with anne until they marry um historians have discussed that i mean no one knows i mean the truth of that
我的意思是，这极其重要。但这也是事实：安妮，这是安妮在历史上非凡的作用。自古以来国王就有情妇。亨利也有过情妇，包括安妮的姐姐玛丽。而真正引人注目的是，安妮说：‘我不会做你的情妇，我必须做你的妻子。’这是否意味着——显然这不是你在儿童读物里深入探讨的细节，是的——这是否意味着亨利直到结婚前都没有和安妮同房？呃，历史学家们讨论过这个问题。我的意思是，没有人知道。我的意思是，真相是……
what makes the six wives so so fascinating i think for people writing popular history books is there's actually so little that we do know that you can fill in a lot with your because it's i mean it's it's what it's kind of six years isn't it six seven years i mean i can't remember somebody like great matter somebody like david starkey or somebody like that says at some point she didn't sleep with him but she may have satisfied him by other means what's the sex act yeah exactly sort of some sort of bill clinton style you know um okay we're going to get distinction this is going to be an adult rated episode so we should rain back on that um yes okay so of course this then gets ground dragged into the great mangle that turns out to be the reformation yeah which hemorrhage has been against actually
为什么六位王后如此令人着迷？我认为对于写通俗历史书的人来说，是因为我们实际知道的太少了，以至于你可以用……因为这毕竟是——大约六年时间，对吧？六、七年。我的意思是，我不记得了，像大卫·斯塔基这样的大人物在某个时候曾说过，她没有和他同房，但她可能通过其他方式满足了他。什么性行为？是的，完全是某种比尔·克林顿风格的，你知道的。好吧，我们要划分界限了，这将是一集限制级节目，所以我们应该收敛一下。是的，好吧，所以这随后被拖入了后来被称为宗教改革的巨大绞肉机中。是的，而亨利对此其实一直持反对态度，
early because of course he'd written in defense of the seven sacraments against luther yeah and he had this luther called him a mad fool with a frothy mouth so i think i think we should do another episode on the reformation in england of course we should of course multiple episodes so let's keep the focus on on on the wives yeah okay so basically the problem is that um the pope has just been taken prisoner by the emperor yeah charles v troops yeah have stormed rome so the Pope is in no position to allow Henry to divorce the Emperor's aunt. No. The Emperor would be livid about... Yeah.
早期的时候，因为他曾写过捍卫七件圣事的著作来反对路德。是的，路德曾称他为“满口白沫的疯狂傻瓜”。所以我觉得，我觉得我们应该再做一期关于英国宗教改革的节目。当然应该，当然要做多期节目，所以让我们把重点放在王后们身上。是的，好吧。基本上问题在于，教皇刚刚被皇帝的军队——查理五世的军队——俘虏了。罗马被攻陷了，所以教皇根本没有立场允许亨利离婚去娶皇帝的姑妈。不。皇帝会气急败坏……是的。
There's a kind of deadlock. And the Pope plays for time. And Henry's getting increasingly frustrated, perhaps in every way. Who knows? Yes. And so, with the help of Thomas thomas cromwell as in um wolf hall yeah henry finds a way to cut the gordian knot which is basically to repudiate papal supremacy to declare himself um basically in charge of the church in england and in this way he's able to marry anne exactly
这有点陷入了僵局。教皇在拖延时间。而亨利的挫败感越来越强烈，也许各方面都是如此。谁知道呢？是的。于是，在托马斯·克伦威尔（也就是《狼厅》里的那个）的帮助下，亨利找到了一种斩断戈迪安结的方法，那就是基本上否定教皇的至高地位，宣布他自己基本上是英格兰教会的负责人。通过这种方式，他得以娶了安妮。完全正确。
and poor old catherine gets shoved off to a succession of country houses um you know basically again she like anne as with anne the remarkable thing is she doesn't take the easy option either so the easy option would be to say fair enough you know we shouldn't have got married in the first place it was against the laws of god i'm off to a nunnery you know where i'll probably live in very you know i'll be well looked after and properly treated and stuff and but she basically says no i haven't come all this way and put up with all this thomas cromwell who who's whose maneuverings basically kind of back her out i mean, he's terribly impressed by her, isn't he? Yeah, he says she should have been a man.
而可怜的凯瑟琳则被赶到了一处又一处乡间宅邸。你知道的，基本上，她和安妮一样，了不起的地方在于她也没有选择轻松的路。轻松的路本来是说：‘好吧，我们一开始就不该结婚，这违背了上帝的法律，我要去修道院了。’你知道，在那里我可能会过得很（你知道的，我会得到很好的照顾和妥善的对待之类的）。但她基本上说：‘不，我没有历经千辛万苦，也没有忍受这一切（托马斯·克伦威尔的阴谋基本上把她逼到了绝境）。’我的意思是，他对她印象深刻，对吧？是的，他说她本该是个男人。
If she'd been a man, she'd be one of the greatest figures in Christendom. Because basically, she defies him in public at this incredible trial. I mean, no wonder Channel 5 commissioners like this. The trial scene where this aged cardinal, this sort of Italian mafioso has come from, been sent from Rome, cardinal campeggio
如果她是个男人，她本会成为基督教世界最伟大的人物之一。因为基本上，她在这个不可思议的审判中公开抗命。难怪第5频道（Channel 5）的制片人喜欢这个。审判的场景是，这位年迈的红衣主教，一个从罗马派来的意大利黑手党式的人物，坎佩焦红衣主教——
and uh he's sitting there with cardinal woolsey and she basically stands up and humiliates henry in front of the whole all this audience and then when when when it becomes obligatory to swear the oath yeah uh you know i mean this is this is what does for Thomas More. He goes to the block over it. Both Catherine and Mary, her daughter, refused to swear it. So, I mean, there's kind of slight sense of jeopardy there. I mean, obviously, Henry, you know, he's not going to execute the emperor's...
他坐在沃尔西红衣主教旁边，而她基本上站起身来，在所有这些观众面前羞辱了亨利。然后，当宣誓效忠成为强制性的时候，你知道的，我的意思是，这就是托马斯·莫尔的死因。他为此走上了断头台。凯瑟琳和她的女儿玛丽都拒绝宣誓。所以，我的意思是，有一种轻微的危机感。当然，亨利，你知道的，他不会处决皇帝的……
No, he can't execute her. He can execute other people. But it's so telling, you're dead right, that he doesn't. And there's absolutely no question, really, that there's no danger of him executing Catherine so so Catherine so Catherine gets um she she kind of gets retired doesn't she um Mary so she and she basically kind of wastes away and and dies gets buried in Peterborough Cathedral yeah and to this day flowers are laid about her graves and
不，他不能处决她。他可以处决其他人。但这就很说明问题了——你说得完全对——他没有处决她。而且毫无疑问，真正没有危险的是他不会处决凯瑟琳。所以凯瑟琳，凯瑟琳被……她基本上退休了，对吧？玛丽……所以她基本上日渐消瘦，然后死去，被安葬在彼得伯勒大教堂。是的，直到今天，人们还把鲜花放在她的墓前，还有...
pomegranates the the symbol of Aragon. She's very, very popular with the British, with the English people. Yes. So she is seen as the queen. She is. Anne Boleyn, for that reason, is not popular. I think we should take a break at this point. Sure.
石榴，阿拉贡的象征。她在英国人、在英格兰人民中非常非常受欢迎。是的，所以她被视为真正的王后。她的确是。正因为如此，安妮·博林并不受欢迎。我想我们这时应该休息一下。当然。
And I think that when we come back, we should look at the rise and fall of Anne Boleyn and then have a canter through the remaining four queens. Yeah. Jolly good. See you after the break. We tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We're talking The Six Wives of Henry VIII.
我想当我们回来时，我们应该看看安妮·博林的崛起与衰落，然后快速浏览其余四位王后。好的，很好。休息后再见。我们来告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、独家番外以及提前购买现场活动门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。我们正在讨论亨利八世的六个妻子。
We've only got on onto the two first ones. Catherine of Aragon, who died just before the commercial break. And Anne Boleyn, who is now Queen Dominic. But not popular. No, people used to sort of mutter. They called her, what do they call her, kind of naughty strumpet and all this kind of stuff.
我们才讲到前两位。阿拉贡的凯瑟琳，她在广告插播前不久去世了；还有安妮·博林，她现在是王后了，多米尼克。但并不受欢迎。是的，人们过去常常嘟囔。他们叫她——他们叫她什么来着？某种淘气的荡妇之类的。
A naughty goggle-eyed witch. That's my favourite son. My favourite voice of the people. about it's getting after her yes exactly she's not popular she's not seeing some but her unpopularity wouldn't have mattered if she'd given henry a son yeah once again she gives him a daughter elizabeth yes um mary has been uh kind of cast aside so elizabeth is now the heir but obviously henry wants a son he's got to have a son he's obsessed with it now and gets pregnant again henry's in a tournament yes fall briefly it looks like he's dead yeah so but he comes around but he sustained a serious sporting injury. This is the ulcer. I know myself how demoralising sporting injuries can be.
一个淘气的凸眼魔女。这是我最喜欢的俚语。我最喜欢的民间声音。关于……在攻击她。是的，完全如此。她不受欢迎，她不被视为……但如果她给亨利生了个儿子，她的不受欢迎也就无所谓了。是的，她再次生了个女儿伊丽莎白。是的，玛丽被抛在一边了，所以伊丽莎白现在是王位继承人。但很明显亨利想要个儿子，他必须有个儿子，他现在对此着迷了。安妮再次怀孕，亨利在一次比武大会上落马。是的，短暂地看起来他已经死了。是的，但他醒过来了，但他受了严重的运动伤害。这就是溃疡。我深知运动伤害会让人多么士气低落。
So a bit of sympathy for him there. But Anne is so upset by this that basically she miscarries. Exactly. That's exactly what happens just after the tournament accident. OK, and so what happens then? Well, then it's a slightly confusing and and murky series of events where basically what really happens is anne and henry have always had a very tempestuous relationship completely unlike his relationship with katherine of aragon so there's been a lot of quarreling um and he's sometimes said to her you know i can kind of drop you as quickly as i
所以对他有点同情。但安妮对此非常难过，以至于她流产了。没错。这正是比武事故后发生的事情。好的，那接下来发生了什么？好吧，接下来的事情是一系列有些混乱和阴暗的发展。基本上真正发生的情况是，安妮和亨利一直有着非常暴烈的关系，这与他和阿拉贡凯瑟琳的关系完全不同。所以有很多争吵，而且他有时会对她说，你知道的，我可以像……一样把你甩掉
picked you up because she's spiky and she's acerbic and she's very quick with the kind of put downs and she's hot tempered herself so war war war that's all you ever think of Henry Tudor very good so yes she's um there's a lot of bickering and in the midst of all this she falls out with his chief minister Thomas Cromwell and it's partly because Cromwell what really wants an alliance he wants he's basically Think of him as a kind of prime minister. He really wants an alliance with Charles V, with the Empire, against the French. But basically Anne is an obstacle to that because the Emperor will never do a deal as long as he has to recognise Anne as the Queen.
选你是因为她尖锐、尖酸，而且非常擅长挖苦人，她自己脾气也很火爆，所以针锋相对、吵个不停，这就是你对亨利·都铎的所有想法，亨利·都铎，非常对。所以，是的，她嗯……有很多争吵，而在这一切当中，她和他的首席大臣托马斯·克伦威尔闹翻了，部分原因是克伦威尔真的非常想要结盟，他想要——基本上你可以把他当作某种首相。他非常想与查理五世、与帝国结盟，来对抗法国。但基本上安妮是其中的一个障碍，因为只要皇帝还必须承认安妮为王后，就绝不会跟他们达成协议。
Anne is also a threat to Cromwell's spending plans and his ambitions. He wants to be the man and she basically thinks she should be in charge henry i mean henry is basically inventing whitehall palace at this point isn't he yes i mean he's a massive development luxury development spending money that he doesn't really have that's exactly cromwell is about to serve it up to him by dissolving the monastery by dissolving the monasteries so there's a sort of internal power struggle and i think cromer effectively orchestrates the whole thing he basically realizes that if he can say to if he can play on henry's fear and he and the fact that he's always falling out with that and basically say do you know what anne is
安妮也对克伦威尔的花钱计划和野心构成了威胁。他想成为核心人物，而她基本上认为自己才应该掌权。亨利，我是说亨利基本上就是在此时此地创建白厅宫的，对吧？是的，我是说这是一个巨大的开发项目，奢侈的开发项目，花着他其实并不富有的钱。没错，而克伦威尔正准备通过解散修道院来为他提供资金——通过解散修道院。所以这是一种内部权力斗争，而且我认为克伦威尔实际上策划了整件事。他基本上意识到，如果他能对……如果他能利用亨利的恐惧，利用他俩总是闹翻的事实，然后基本上说：“你知道吗，安妮在……”
plotting against you she's been betraying you with all these blokes including her own brother a court musician some of your own friends all of this and this. And the amazing thing is that Henry just swallows it. I mean, that's a sign maybe of his deep insecurity. That when Cromwell tells him this stuff, there's no question of, you know, he'll have a little meeting with Anne to talk through their marital troubles or he just says, fine, you know, killer. And I think that's the point at which the story crosses over from, frankly, the usual, you know,
密谋对付你，她背叛了你，和所有这些家伙鬼混，包括她自己的兄弟、宫廷乐师、你的一些朋友，所有这些乱七八糟的事。”最神奇的是，亨利竟然全盘接受了。我的意思是，这或许表明了他内心深处的极度不安全感。当克伦威尔对他说这些事时，根本不存在什么“他会和安妮开个小会来谈谈他们的婚姻危机”之类的问题，他只是说：“好吧，你知道的，杀了她。”而我认为，正是在这一点上，故事跨越了界限，坦率地说，不再是那种通常的……
because a lot of this stuff before that is, it's not that unprecedented. But I think the point at which Henry says, fine, she's got to go, we'll kill her, that is the point where this becomes a really extraordinary story. Yeah. Okay, so Anne goes to the tower
因为之前的好多事情，其实并不是那么史无前例。但我觉得，当亨利说“好吧，她必须死，我们要杀了她”时，正是在这一点上，这个故事变成了一个真正非凡的故事。好吧，所以安妮去了伦敦塔，
and then she goes to the block yeah um and henry meanwhile has um he's got a new crush yes who is a wiltshire girl uh yes so probably your favorite yeah absolutely yes so uh jane seymour um who who grows up in wolf hall as in as in the novel um and she's very much, she's very much a Wiltshire girl. So she, she loves ponies. She's got a dog. Dogs.
然后她上了断头台。是的，而亨利与此同时，他有了……他有了新的迷恋对象，是的，是谁呢？一个威尔特郡姑娘，哦是的，所以可能正是你的最爱。绝对是的。所以，简·西摩，她在狼厅长大——就像小说里那样——她非常有，非常典型地是个威尔特郡姑娘。所以她，她喜欢小马。她有一只狗。狗。
Basically, do you know what we know nothing at all about? No one knows anything about Jane Seymour. So the stuff about dogs, I find this hilarious. Actually, the six wives of him, the eighth historiography,
基本上，你知道有什么是我们一无所知的吗？没有人对简·西摩有一点了解。所以关于狗的事情，我发现这太滑稽了。实际上，关于他的六个妻子，第八版史学研究，
there'll be a source that basically says once she was in the same room as a dog. And then if you sort of, if you trace that through through the books by the time you get to sort of books published in the 1990s they're saying the most famous dog lover in english history invented dogs just because people are desperate to flesh out these kind of bodice ripping kind of histories of the tudors she's a wheelchair girl who loves ponies and loves dogs i'm not no one's going to change my view on that. And she's sweet, kind, marries Henry, gives him a son, Edward VI. He dies.
会出现这样一份史料：基本上说有一次她和一只狗处在同一个房间里。然后，如果你顺着这个线索读下去，到了20世纪90年代出版的那些书时，他们就会说她是英国历史上最有名的爱狗人士，甚至还“发明了狗”，仅仅是因为人们迫切地想要丰富这些带有香艳色彩的都铎王朝历史。她是个喜欢小马和狗的威尔特郡姑娘，我不会——没有人能改变我对这一点的看法。她很温柔、善良，嫁给了亨利，为他生了个儿子，爱德华六世。她死了。
But dies. Very unlucky. I mean, Henry's very unlucky. He's gone for Jane Seymour, and actually that would probably work out completely fine. She clearly knows exactly what's expected of her, which is basically it's been little more than a sort of pretty accessory. There's no reason to believe they would have fallen out. It would have all been fine.
但她死了。非常不幸。我是说，亨利太不幸了。他选了简·西摩，实际上这本来可能会完全顺利的。她显然很清楚别人对她的期望，基本上就是作为一个漂亮的附属品。没有理由认为他们会闹翻。一切都会好起来的。
It's just incredibly bad luck that she dies just after giving birth to Edward VI. Okay, and now we come to my favourite queen. Everyone's favourite queen, surely. Everyone's favourite queen. Who you, in your book, she was bland she was boring she was german well well those things are those things are all true i mean apologies to her um she's not bland well she's seen as bland by henry she is german so we're talking anne of cleves anne of cleves who is thomas cromwell trying to find who wants so the problem is henry by this point, is he's burnt his bridges with Catholic Europe.
只是极其倒霉的是，她刚生完爱德华六世就去世了。好吧，现在我们来谈谈我最喜欢的王后。毫无疑问，这也是所有人最喜欢的王后。所有人最喜欢的王后。而她在你的书中，她被描写得很平淡，很无聊，她是个德国人。好吧，好吧，这些事情——这些事情都是真的。向她道个歉，嗯……她并不平淡。好吧，她在亨利看来很平淡，她确实是德国人，所以我们说的是克里夫斯的安妮。克里夫斯的安妮，托马斯·克伦威尔正试图找一个……谁想要……所以问题是，亨利到了这个时候，他已经和天主教欧洲彻底决裂了。
And so essentially Thomas Cromwell, a devout Protestant, wants to find him a Protestant bride. Anne of Cleves comes. I mean, actually, her father's not Protestant. No, but they're very close. They played a kind of cunning middle game. They're very close to the sort of protestant league of of german states and so famously yeah um they send holbein the great painter over to to paint her comes back
所以基本上，托马斯·克伦威尔这个虔诚的新教徒，想为他找一个新教新娘。克里夫斯的安妮来了。我是说，实际上，她父亲并不是新教徒。不，但他们非常亲密。他们玩了一种狡猾的中间路线游戏。他们与德国各州的新教同盟非常亲密，所以众所周知的，是的，嗯……他们派伟大画家小荷尔拜因过去给她画像，回来后——
henry looks there goes yeah that's very nice yeah she comes over and and everyone thinks she's very pretty you know this is the thing the flanders mare stuff people call it the flanders is totally untrue she comes over and everybody says she's absolutely fine. She's not a stunner. She's not a kind of Victoria's Secret model in waiting. But she is absolutely, utterly inoffensive and fine. The problem is Henry, the one thing that, so we had some questions and people said about Henry being a sex addict.
亨利看了一眼，说：“哦，这挺好的，嗯。”她来了，每个人都觉得她很漂亮，你知道，就是这么回事。关于她是“法兰德斯母马”的那些说法，人们这么叫她，完全是不真实的。她来了，每个人都说她完全没问题。她算不上倾国倾城，也不是维多利亚的秘密候补超模。但她绝对、完全是无害的，挺好的。问题是亨利，唯一的一点——所以我们之前收到了一些提问，有人说亨利是个性瘾者。
He absolutely wasn't a sex addict. What Henry was was a child almost childish romantic he he was sort of utterly raised on all this arthurian romance stuff he wants an aguinovia he wants somebody that he will he can be feel swept up with so he he does this disastrous yeah absolutely laughable introduction to her when she's come to england and he and his mates do they go back to the old prince harry tactic well it's it is that kind of woof woof thing they dress up as they literally dress up as robin hood and the merry men and they pitch up and i think rochester isn't it it's in rochester at the bishop's palace in multi-colored hoods they burst into her room and she's sitting there with a german idea what's going on and they're watching bear baiting and and she's looking
他绝对不是个性瘾者。亨利实际上是一个孩子，几乎是个孩子气的浪漫主义者。他简直完全是在所有这些亚瑟王传奇故事的熏陶下长大的，他想要一个绝代佳人，他想要一个能让自己感到被深深迷住的人。所以他做了一次灾难性的——是的，绝对荒谬的——与她的初次见面。当时她刚来到英国，他和他的哥们儿们做的事——他们又用回了哈里王子的老套路吗？嗯，确实是那种“汪汪”的把戏。他们乔装打扮，字面意义上打扮成罗宾汉和他的快乐罗宾汉党徒，然后闯了过来，我想是在罗彻斯特，对吧？是在罗彻斯特的主教宫殿里，戴着五颜六色的风帽，他们闯进了她的房间。当时她正坐在那里，跟一个德国人……完全不知道发生了什么，他们正在看斗熊，而她正看着——
out the window so these clowns burst in in these hoods and she just kind of looks at them and mutters in german and won't even look them in the eye and is embarrassed by it and henry never ever forgives her for that i mean from, from that moment, he basically says, she's no good. I don't like her. I've taken her against her. Cromwell says, I can't, you know, you've got to go ahead with it. So he goes ahead with it.
窗外。所以这群小丑戴着风帽闯了进来，她只是看了他们一眼，用德语嘟囔了几句，甚至不愿正眼看他们，对此感到很尴尬。而亨利从那以后就再也没有原谅过她。我是说，从那一刻起，他基本上就说：“她不行。我不喜欢她。我对她产生了好感。”克伦威尔说：“我不行，你知道的，你必须继续推进。”于是他继续推进。
They postpone it by a day or something. Goes to bed with her. The next morning he says, out of the question. He goes to see the doctors. This is the hilarious thing. He goes to see his doctors and he says, what should we do? I can't, I can't, you know, can't do anything. And they say and they say not much we can really do about this you're not going to get a son unless well but but so so not good enough she has to go brings down cromwell who goes to the block
他们把婚礼推迟了一天左右。和她同床共枕。第二天早上他说：“免谈。”他去找医生。这就是最滑稽的地方。他去找他的御医，说：“我们该怎么办？我不能，我不能，你知道的，什么也做不了。”他们说——他们说：“我们对此也无能为力。你不可能生个儿子，除非……”嗯，但是，但是——所以，这还不够好，她必须走。这导致了克伦威尔的下台，他也上了断头台。
yeah i mean all these kind of great figures of the the tudor court who who basically every time the wheel turns and another wife goes, they go as well. Yes. So Cromwell goes out. And, but the thing I like about Anne of Cleves is that she, she, she plays her hand well.
是的，我是说，都铎宫廷里所有这些伟大的人物，基本上每次时运转换、一个妻子下台时，他们也跟着下台。是的。所以克伦威尔出局了。但是，我喜欢克里夫斯的安妮的一点是，她——她把牌打得很好。
Very well. So she comes with a deal, doesn't he? So essentially she, she stays in England. She doesn't have to go back kind of humiliated and broken to her, to her father. She stays in England.
非常好。所以她带着一笔交易来了，不是吗？所以基本上，她留在了英国。她不必灰头土脸、身败名裂地回到她父亲身边。她留在了英国。
She gets a brilliant, she kind of gets two palaces and loads to her father she stays in england she gets a brilliant she kind of gets two palaces and loads of properties so dominic i the sussex archaeological society have you come across this um i'm aware you're very enthusiastic well it's a wonderful organization it's it's um britain's oldest county archaeological society 175 years this year um and basically most of its properties at some point were owned by anna of cleves were they so all over sussex and actually all over i mean all over south southeast england you come across you know some beautiful tudor property and the guidebook will say it was well she was open the equivalent of tens and tens of millions of pounds um but the weird thing is
她得到了一个极好的——她得到了两座宫殿和大量的财产。所以多米尼克，苏塞克斯考古学会，你听说过这个吗？嗯，我知道你对此非常热心。嗯，这是一个绝佳的组织，它是——嗯，英国最古老的郡级考古学会，今年成立175周年了。基本上，它的绝大多数财产在某个时期都曾属于克里夫斯的安妮，是吗？所以整个苏塞克斯郡，实际上还有整个——我是说整个英格兰东南部，你都会遇到一些美丽的都铎时期房产，而导游书会说，那是——她拥有相当于几千万、数千万英镑的资产。但奇怪的是，
she then stays in england all this time but then she runs out of money so basically having been a good girl she clearly just sort of went mad went wild didn't she and just spent all this money on something i don't know what um and because but then by then sort of later on she's constantly complaining that everything in england is too expensive yeah it's that classic thing of yeah i love her a european person who's moved to england but basically just whinges the whole time about the weather the everything's too expensive she's really don't pay her enough respect even her even when she dies much later on she's the longest lived of all the wives when she dies um there's a heat wave and so the government says to people don't go to anna's funeral so nobody has a state funeral doesn't she so nobody but nobody goes
她后来一直留在英国，但接着她钱花光了。所以基本上，她虽然曾经是个乖女孩，但显然只是发了疯、变得狂野，对吧？把所有的钱都花在了一些——我不知道是什么的东西上——因为，但到了后来，到了晚期，她经常抱怨英国的每一样东西都太贵了。是的，这就是那种经典的——是的，我喜欢她，一个搬到英国的欧洲人，基本上却一直在抱怨天气，抱怨什么都太贵了。人们真的没有给予她足够的尊重，甚至在她很久以后去世时——她是所有妻子中最长寿的——当她去世时，正好赶上一场热浪，于是政府对人们说：“不要去参加安妮的葬礼。”所以没有人举行国葬，不是吗？所以没有人——真的没有人去，
because it's too hot so i mean i would have gone i would have gone she's the queen of my heart of his funeral so nobody has a state funeral doesn't she so nobody but nobody goes because it's too hot so i mean i would have gone i would have gone she's the queen of my heart um but meanwhile talking of good girls and bad girls yeah um henry's fixed his eye on a young teenager called katherine howard yeah um so this is this is this is quite badly this is this is a this is a slightly tragic story isn't it he marries Catherine of Howard sorry he marries Catherine Howard there's a big age gap at this stage and this is the point at which he has definitively become a whale so he's very very fat and um he just takes a fancy to her and at this point he's in ridiculous
因为天气太热了。所以，我是说，我要是去了，我一定会去的，她是我心中的挚爱。参加她的葬礼，所以没有人举行国葬，不是吗？所以没有人——真的没有人去，因为天气太热了。所以，我是说，我要是去了，我一定会去的，她是我心中的挚爱。嗯，不过与此同时，说到好女孩和坏女孩，是的，嗯——亨利看上了一个叫凯瑟琳·霍华德的年轻少女，是的。所以，这个——这个——这个有点糟糕，这是一个——这是一个稍微有点悲剧的故事，对吧？他娶了凯瑟琳·霍华德——抱歉，他娶了凯瑟琳·霍华德。在这个阶段，他们之间存在着巨大的年龄差距，而且这也是他彻底变成一个“胖头鲸”的时候——他变得非常非常胖，嗯——他就是看上了她。而在此时，他正处于荒谬的……
kind of midlife crisis um stage she so she is basically the marital equivalent of buying a bright red sports car absolutely she and she's sort of pushed in front of him by the howard family they notice him looking at her and they push her in front and they basically coach her oh well you can woo the king this way you know always laugh at his jokes always admire his ulcer whatever hot and uh she marries him and uh everything is fine for a while and he dotes upon he gets up early and goes hunting to try and lose a bit of weight and and sort of try to impress her but basically he then discovers because um the archbishop of canterbury cranmer gives him a note that says i've got very bad news about your wife she's a she's been carrying on with men like a
某种中年危机……阶段。她——所以她基本上相当于婚姻里的“买一辆亮红色的跑车”。绝对是的，她——而且她被霍华德家族推到了他面前。他们注意到他在看她，就把她推了出去，并基本上指导她：“哦，你可以这样讨好国王，你知道的，总是笑话他的笑话，总是赞美他的溃疡，无论多热。”然后她嫁给了他。嗯，有一段时间一切都很好，他极其宠爱她。他早起去打猎，试图减掉一点体重，并试图给她留下深刻印象。但基本上，随后他发现——因为坎特伯雷大主教克兰默递给他一张纸条，上面写着：“我有关于你妻子的非常糟糕的消息。她一直在和一些男人鬼混，比如……”
music teacher and stuff before she married you which henry can kind of forgive but then it turns out that she's been carrying on with other men while they were married thomas culpepper a man called thomas culpepper who's a very bad man indeed he's basically a rapist um and thomas culpepper is one of henry's sort of prince harry style he's he's a bougies habitue who um yeah yeah exactly he's been carrying on with k Howard and again you know Henry again because he can because she's not royal she's not from a foreign you know dynastic house or something he just basically he's humiliated and there's these dreadful scenes in front of his council where he's sobbing like a child yeah you lied to me you told me she was oh I'm so unhappy oh
音乐老师之类的，在她嫁给你之前。这一点亨利还能原谅，但随后事实证明，在他们结婚期间，她一直在和别的男人鬼混——托马斯·卡尔佩珀，一个名叫托马斯·卡尔佩珀的男人，他确实是个极坏的人，基本上是个强奸犯。而且托马斯·卡尔佩珀是亨利的某种“哈里王子风格”的死党。他是一个花花公子常客，嗯——对，对，没错，他一直跟凯瑟琳·霍华德鬼混。同样，亨利又一次——因为他可以，因为她不是王室成员，不是来自外国王朝家族或诸如此类的背景——他基本上感到自己受到了羞辱，在御前会议上出现了那些可怕的场景，他像个孩子一样号啕大哭：“哦，你骗了我！你告诉我她是……哦，我很不开心，哦——”
and she has to go she gets at Hampton Court doesn't it because you've already sneered at this story that Catherine Howard's ghost still haunts Hampton Court she's executed at the Tower of London she gets arrested at Hampton Court and she's trying to get to Henry in his chapel and her screams
然后她不得不离开。她是在汉普顿宫被捕的，对吧？——因为你刚才还对这个故事冷嘲热讽，说凯瑟琳·霍华德的鬼魂至今仍在汉普顿宫游荡。她在伦敦塔被处决，是在汉普顿宫被捕的。当时她正试图去找在小教堂里的亨利，而她的尖叫声
to this day can be heard echoing around this is another good example this is another brilliant example of the inflation of Tor history all right so um come all elton she's um there's a story the one source that describes this says that uh the the dancing instructors arrive at her rooms and are sent away by the guards who say there's no more time to dance basically she's been arrested but that's become inflated in all the sort of various popular biographies of katherine howard that she was dancing one day when the guards burst in and drag her by her hair through the door or something but all i mean anyway she she dies it's actually a dreadful dreadful scene you can imagine it she's so young she's a teenager she's shaking you know
至今仍能在周围回荡。这是另一个很好的例子，这是托铎历史夸张化的又一个绝佳例子。好吧，所以——听着，埃尔顿，她是个——有个故事，唯一一个描述这件事的史料说，舞蹈教练来到她的房间，被卫兵打发走了，卫兵说：“没时间跳舞了。”基本上她已经被捕了。但这在关于凯瑟琳·霍华德的各种通俗传记中被夸大了，说什么她当时正在跳舞，卫兵突然闯进来，拽着她的头发把她拖过门之类。但总之，不管怎样，她死了。实际上这是一个非常可怕、可怕的场景。你能想象得到，她那么年轻，是个十几岁的少女，浑身发抖，你知道的，
they have to help her up to the scaffold the guards because she's shaking so much and she's so tearful and see the block before she died didn because she's shaking so much. And she's so tearful. She wanted to see the block before she died, didn't she? Yes, she did. Horrible kind of detail. She's clearly utterly traumatised. So that's actually, although I think David Starkey possibly describes her as a sort of, in his account, she's a sort of strumpet and all this stuff.
卫兵不得不扶着她走上断头台，因为她抖得太厉害了，而且泪流满面。她死前想看看断头台，不是吗？——因为她抖得太厉害了，而且泪流满面。她死前想看看断头台，不是吗？是的，确实如此。这是一种可怕的细节。她显然受到了极大的精神创伤。所以这实际上——尽管我认为大卫·斯塔基在对她的记述中，可能把她描述成了一种……某种荡妇之类的东西。
I mean, she's just a teenager. It's a very, very harsh. She's posted something un strumpet and all this stuff. I mean, she's just a teenager. You know, it's a very, very harsh... Who's posted something unwise on TikTok. Exactly. Who's been cancelled. Well, it was literally cancelled. Okay, so, and then the very last one, the one who survives, Catherine Parr.
我是说，她只是个十几岁的少女。这是一个非常、非常严厉的……发布了某些不明智言论的荡妇之类的东西。我是说，她只是个十几岁的少女，你知道的，这是一个非常、非常严厉的……在TikTok上发布了不明智内容的人。没错。被取消文化抵制的人。好吧，她确实被字面意义上的取消了。好吧，所以，至于最后一位，那个活下来的人，凯瑟琳·帕尔。
Yes, often regarded as a bit boring, I think greatly unfairly. She's a very impressive person. She's married twice. She's made two very good marriages. Once to a weedy but rich fellow who dies wants to a rich um older man called lord latimer a widower who's very kind to her and leaves her money and houses and stuff um she really wants to marry somebody else at this
是的，通常被认为有点无聊，我认为这大大不公。她是一个非常了不起的人。她结过两次婚。她有过两次非常好的婚姻。一次是嫁给一个孱弱但富有、后来死去的家伙。想嫁给一个富有、年长的、名叫拉蒂默勋爵的鳏夫，他对她很好，留给她钱和房子之类的东西。她在这个时候其实想嫁给另一个人，
point but henry basically has his eye on her he wants an old widow well not old i mean she's not old but he wants somebody a bit more experienced. He's not going down the teenage route again. And she's very Protestant. I think that's one reason why she does it, is that she thinks, I will be able to advance the cause of the true religion. And obviously, although we don't have terrific sources for this,
但亨利基本上看上了她。他想要一个老寡妇——好吧，也不是老，我是说她不老——但他想要一个更有经验的人。他不再走少女路线了。而且她非常新教。我认为这是她这么做的一个原因，就是她觉得：“我将能够推进真正信仰的事业。”显然，尽管我们对此没有极好的史料，
you can well imagine that there are people at court who are Protestants who sort of encourage her, say, you should do this and so she survives and she and she survived she's very clever because there's a point a couple of points at which it looks like henry might get rid of her as well for arguing with him about religion but she's very quick she always goes into his she goes into his room and she says oh i only talk to you about religion to take your mind off your leg um i just love having instruction from you please mansplain to me a bit more about indulgences and purgatory and henry loves all this you know he he has no sense of irony clearly so he just sucks all this up and then after and then after um henry dies she marries her true love
你也可以想象得到，宫廷里有一些新教徒会鼓励她，对她说：“你应该这么做。”于是她活了下来。而且她活了下来，她非常聪明。因为有好几次，有那么几次看起来亨利也可能会除掉她——因为她跟争论宗教问题。但她非常机灵。她总是走进他的房间，说：“哦，我跟你谈论宗教，只是为了转移你对腿疾的注意力……我只是喜欢听你的教导，请再向我多‘爹味说教’一点关于赎罪券和炼狱的知识吧。”亨利喜欢这一切，你知道的，他显然一点幽默感都没有，所以他把这些全盘接受了。然后——在亨利死后，她嫁给了她的真爱，
doesn't she yeah thomas seymour and then there's some very strange kind of rape elizabeth very strange business so yeah he tickles he's tickling elizabeth and then one day and she joins in she holds elizabeth down and they both tickle her but then later on one morning she gets up and she finds him trying to kiss elizabeth so elizabeth poor elizabeth has to go um not then she dies a couple of years after right so so that's that's those are the six wives now i i was talking about this yesterday to my daughter eliza and her friend anna um who are in the midst of watching love island i imagine you're a big love island massive love yeah yeah so they they they kind of they got to wondering um which of them basically which of them would
不是吗？是的，托马斯·西摩。然后发生了一些非常奇怪的、某种强暴伊丽莎白的……非常奇怪的事情。所以，是的，他挠痒痒——他在挠伊丽莎白的痒痒，然后有一天，她也加入了。她按住伊丽莎白，两人一起挠她痒痒。但后来有一天早上，她起床发现他在试图亲吻伊丽莎白。所以可怜的伊丽莎白不得不离开——不是那个时候，她几年后才去世。好吧，所以这就是那六个王后。现在，我昨天跟我的女儿伊莉莎以及她的朋友安娜谈起过这件事，她们正在看《求爱岛》（Love Island）。我想你也是个《求爱岛》的超级粉丝吧？超级粉，是的，是的。所以她们——她们开始琢磨，她们当中基本上——她们当中谁会赢得《求爱岛》呢？
win love island yeah so shall i tell you the so explain to me i i'm lying when i say my love which of them, basically, which of them would win Love Island? Yeah. So shall I tell you the... So explain to me, I'm lying when I say I'm a Love Island fan, and Love Island, do you get voted off by the public? Or do you have to... I think so. I've only seen it occasionally. But I think you go in, and the idea is that you go into the, what is it, the Casa Amor.
是的。所以我来告诉你——向我解释一下，我说我是个《求爱岛》粉丝是在撒谎，而《求爱岛》里，你是被公众投票淘汰的吗？还是你必须……我想是这样的。我只是偶尔看过。但我想你进去之后，目标是去那个什么地方，叫什么来着，卡萨阿莫尔（Casa Amor）。
That's how it's called. Yes. And basically, you have to get off with someone. Right. You have to stay a couple. And all the other ones are trying to break you up and that kind of thing. So it is quite tutor court.
就是那个地方。是的。基本上，你得和某人勾搭上。没错。你必须保持配对。而所有其他人都在试图拆散你们，诸如此类。所以这其实很像都铎宫廷。
Yeah, very tutor court. But obviously, part of it is that you then come out and it's about your media profile. So it's not just about doing well within the show. It's also that you then come out and it's about your media profile so it's not just about doing well in the within the show it's also about whether you come out and you're an influencer and yeah and and how you're remembered like you're an influencer tom like i'm an influencer so yeah so i feel a lot of kind of fellow feeling um so they thought the best shall i do it in ascending order do best contestant on on love island so they
是的，非常像都铎宫廷。但显然，其中一部分在于你随后出来之后的媒体形象。所以这不仅仅是关于在节目中表现得好不好。这也是关于你出来之后，这关乎你的媒体形象，所以这不仅仅是关于在节目里表现得好不好，还在于你出来后是否能成为网红，以及——是的——以及人们是如何记住你的，就像你是个网红一样，汤姆，就像我是个网红一样。所以，是的，我有一种同病相连的感觉。所以她们认为最好的——我按升序来列出《求爱岛》的最佳参赛选手吧。她们——
they dissed katherine parr they they had well so anna yeah who is actually spanish so you can guess who's yeah she she said she was a devout protestant who spends a lot of time reading and um she was also voted the least likely to sport fake tan i think katherine parr but katherine parr has been married twice before i mean she knows her way around men i think she's she's got a track record i think she would i don't think she'd win but i think she'd quit herself do you think she'd wear and also the fact that she has this fancy yeah i do because the fact that she has the fancy for this you think she'd wear fake tan? Yeah, I do. Because the fact that she has the fancy for this Thomas Seymour, and Thomas Seymour is a very rakish, roguish sort of fellow.
她们贬低了凯瑟琳·帕尔。她们有——所以安娜，其实是西班牙人，所以你可以猜猜是谁——是的，她说过她是个虔诚的新教徒，花很多时间阅读。而且，嗯，她还被投票选为最不可能涂假美黑的人，我想这是凯瑟琳·帕尔。但凯瑟琳·帕尔之前结过两次婚，我是说她对男人驾轻就熟。我认为她——她有前科，我觉得她不会赢，但我认为她会表现得不错。你觉得她会涂——而且鉴于她对这个——是的，我觉——因为鉴于她对这个——你觉得她会涂假美黑吗？是的，我觉。因为鉴于她对这个托马斯·西摩有迷恋，而托马斯·西摩是个非常放荡、无赖式的家伙。
He would be an excellent Love Island contestant, and I think the fact that she has this mad obsession with him suggests to me there's more to Catherine Parr. You can't have too mad an obsession, because if needs be, you might have to... Anyway, that was Eliza and Anna's verdict. i think they're being misled by her protestantism without they've they really thought protestantism and love island didn't go together clearly to argue um number five is jane seymour just because she was very they said she was very boring yeah she'd just go
他会是一个极佳的《求爱岛》选手，而且我认为她对他这种疯狂的痴迷，表明了凯瑟琳·帕尔还有更多不为人知的一面。你不能有太疯狂的痴迷，因为如果需要的话，你可能不得不……总之，那是伊莉莎和安娜的评判。我认为她们被她的新教信仰误导了，她们真的以为新教信仰和《求爱岛》格格不入，显然可以争论一番。第五名是简·西摩，仅仅因为她非常——她们说她非常无聊，是的，她只会到处对人友好。人们确实这么说，人们确实这么说，但这只是——我认为人们说她无聊，是因为他们不了解——我们对她了解太少了。我是说，她可能确实如此。好吧，是的，但这在《求爱岛》里可吃不开。你对她一无所知。你不会投票让她留下来，对吧？我想也是。
around being nice to people people do say this people do say this but that's only i think people just say that she's boring because they don't, we know so little about her. I mean, she might have been. Well, yeah, but that's no good on Love Island. You don't know anything about her. You're not going to vote to keep her on, are you? I suppose so. She'd blame the editing, wouldn't she?
她会怪剪辑的，对吧？她会怪——是的。她会说：“他们剪掉了我所有的高光片段。”是的，但我觉得这很公平。所以，接下来第五名是克里夫斯的安妮。没错。我很惊讶她能得这个名次。但原因在于，她们说她相当——
She'd blame the. Yes. She'd say they cut out all my best bits. Yeah, but I think that's fair enough. So, and then number five is Anne of Cleves. Right. Which I'm surprised she got that. But the reason for that is that they said she was quite,
她很好地利用了这一点。是的。所以，你知道的，选手们节目结束后出来，会得到某种——你知道的，在《太阳报》上开个专栏什么的，或者拿到赞助合同之类的。所以基本上这就是她所做的。我想是的，你是说她有点像凯蒂·普价（Katie Price）式的人物。她会经常出现在《Hello!》杂志上，或者——是的，嗯——你刚才说——你刚才说“没错，爷爷”吗？我说了，我说了。因为我对凯蒂·普价的了解是——继续，继续吧。
she leveraged it quite well. Yeah. So, you know, contestants come out and they get kind of, you know, column in the sun or whatever and sponsorship deal or whatever. And so basically that's what she does. I suppose so you're saying she's a sort of Katie Price figure. She'd constantly be in Hello Magazine or, um yeah yes um did you say did you say that's right granddad i did i did because of my knowledge of katie price is that move on move on
说真的，第三名是阿拉贡的凯瑟琳。第三名，是的。但我是说她只——好吧，继续。有很多同情分，是的，对她有很大的同情。她会成为——她会是观众的最爱，所以人们会为她感到难过。是的，和两个兄弟之间所有的抓马，这会很受欢迎，显然，我想。而且，根据伊莉莎的说法，非常像艾米和柯蒂斯（Amy and Curtis）。我不知道那是什么意思。那是什么意思？也许我也不知道那是什么意思。可能很多听众也不知道。无论如何，我都无法想象她去参加《求爱岛》。也许她是斐迪南派来的？她们谁都不会去《求爱岛》，这太荒谬了。这有点像我父亲去看《指环王》——
honestly uh number three catherine of aragon number three yeah but i mean she only ever well go on a lot of sympathy yeah um a lot of sympathy for her she'd she'd be um a voter's favorite so people would feel sorry for her yeah there's all the drama with the two brothers that that would play well apparently i suppose um and uh according to eliza very amy and curtis i have no idea what that means what does that mean maybe i don't know what that means either probably lots of listeners i don't see her anyway i can't even see her going on love island maybe she was sent by ferdinand none of them would go on love island that's a ridiculous thing to say that's a bit like when my dad went to see the
当它在电影院上映时，第一部电影，我事后问他：“你觉得怎么样？”他说：“我觉得挺好的，但我就是觉得不太真实。”我说：“哪部分不太真实？”“戒指，那个带龙的背景故事，咕噜，对吧？”还有那个漂浮的巨眼。同样地，死去的都铎王后出现在《求爱岛》上也是不真实的，但为了这个节目，顺着我的思路来，顺着我想法来——我认为阿拉贡的凯瑟琳会赢得很多观众的同情。所以她是观众的最爱，但我看不出——我只是看不出她会像那样随随便便和人卿卿我我。好吧，所以基于这个原因，这就是为什么在她前面的是——
lord of the rings um when it came out the cinema and the first film and i said to him afterwards how did you get on with it he said i thought it was good but i just thought it was implausible but which bit is quite implausible the ring the the backstory with the dragon golem right well the giant eye floating equally it's implausible that dead tudor queens would appear on love island but just for the same run with me run with me uh i think katherine of aragon would get a lot of audience sympathy yeah so she's an audience favorite but i don't see her i just can't see her copping off with people kind of willy-nilly as it were okay so on that for that reason that's why ahead of her
你觉得是谁？安妮·博林还是凯瑟琳·霍华德？我觉得是——我觉得是安妮·博林。不，是凯瑟琳·霍华德。是凯瑟琳·霍华德。所以她会——她们说她会被节目组利用，所以她会被节目组极其严重地剥削。她会是登上《太阳报》头版的那个，对吧？是的。所以节目组会剪辑素材，让她看起来像个……你知道的，个叛徒、某种爱情骗子，是的，他们会的。而且，他们还会喂给她台词让她说，而她大概会天真到真的去说。她会的。但那显然会让她成为一个绝佳的选手。她会非常优秀，但你觉得公众会——你看，我认为她可能会激起英国公众更具审判欲、更恶毒的那一面，他们会调转枪头攻击她，对吧？是的。所以我认为这就是为什么她排在安妮·博林后面位居第二。所以，对安妮·博林的评价——是的，
yeah who do you think it is amberlynn or katherine howard i think it's i think it's amberlynn no it's katherine howard it's katherine howard so she would be you they said she would be used by the producers so she would be massively exploited by the producers she'd be the one on the front page of the sun wouldn't she yeah so the producers would kind of edit the footage to make it look like she was you know a cheat kind of love rat yeah they would um and also they would feed her lines to say and she'd probably be naive enough to say them she would yeah but that would obviously make her a great contestant she would be very good but you think the public would you see that i think it would she would possibly bring out your writing that she would probably bring out the more censorious and the sort of
好斗、敢直言，粉丝最爱。我是说，这无可辩驳。我认为安妮·博林是粉丝的最爱。我认为她是最让人们着迷的王后。但当时可不是粉丝的最爱啊，汤姆。不，但现在一切都在于捕捉时代精神，所以这显然是赢得《求爱岛》的关键——在于捕捉时代精神，而她凭借自己的新教信仰绝对做到了这一点。她是偶像，是的。但当时不是。而且她甚至比克里夫斯的安妮更可能是个成功的网红。好吧，她是个非常成功的网红，正如我们所知。我是说，你可以认为她是英国历史上最成功的网红之一。我认为她对大众而言的不受欢迎——那个淘气的、凸眼女巫的问题——会让她在观众那里付出代价。你看，我觉得她太不受观众欢迎了。我觉得——我觉得我们应该看《求爱岛》，我们应该做——我们应该做一期“历史情侣《求爱岛》”特别节目。历史情侣，也许等下一季吧。我在想富兰克林和埃莉诺·罗斯福，还有克莉奥佩特拉。咱们别选那个在地下堡垒里结婚的家伙了，我觉得那不太合适。
more vicious side of the british public who would turn on her yeah wouldn't they yeah and so i think that that's why she's at number two behind anne boleyn so comments on anne boleyn yeah feisty and vocal a fan favorite i mean that's indisputable i think amberlynn is the fan favorite i think she is the one that the wife that people are most fascinated but not a fan favorite at the time though tom no but now it's all about capturing the zeitgeist so that's apparently the key to winning love is about capturing the zeitgeist which she certainly did with her Protestantism um she's iconic yeah but not then and she's even more than um Anne of Cleves she is the most likely to have been a successful influencer well she was a very successful influencer as we know I mean you could argue she's one of the most
那确实很不合适。我想以此为契机，我们已经聊完了亨利八世。如果没有对希特勒的提及，那就不能算是一期完整的亨利八世节目了，我们应该在那一点结束。感谢大家的耐心聆听，所有人都在听……这来了个非常意想不到的转折。
successful influencers in in English history um I think that her unpopularity the naughty goggle-eyed witch issue um would cost her with the audience you see i think she's so unpopular with the audience i think i think that we should watch love island and we should do um we should do a historical couples love island episode historical couples maybe wait for the next season yeah I'm trying to think of Franklin and Eleanor Roosevelt and Cleopatra let's not do the fellow who got married in the bunker I think that would be inappropriate
是的，确实如此。确实如此。但我认为是个挺有趣的转折。因为我认为这些王后们——亨利八世的六个王后之所以迷人，部分原因在于她们是——甚至是对历史一无所知的人也知道她们。她们确实是。她们是原型，不是吗？好女孩、荡妇、饱受折磨的妻子。她们绝对是——某种几乎略带滑稽色彩的原型，这就是为什么如果他拥有的房产属于考古学会的话……完全是经典的 archetype（原型），那个德国人，那个……好吧。
that would indeed be inappropriate and I think on that note we've done Henry VIII it wouldn't be an episode of Henry VIII without a mention of Hitler we should end at that point. Thank you for your forbearance, everyone in listening to... This took a very unexpected turn.
所以，非常感谢大家的收听。我们周四播出的下一期节目是威廉·达尔林普尔（William Dalrymple）谈东印度公司。希望你们喜欢这个节目。希望你们听得开心。我们很快就会回来。
Yes, it did. It did. But I think quite a fun one. Because I think part of the fascination of the wives, of the six wives of Henry VIII, is that they are... Even people who care
多谢。拜拜。再见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。
nothing about history know about them they do well they're archetypes aren't they the good girl the the strumpets the sort of long-suffering wife they're absolutely they're sort of almost slightly comic archetypes which is why if he owns properties owned by the archaeological society exactly the classic archetype the german the. Okay. Right. So thanks very much for listening. Our next episode coming out on Thursday is the East India Company with Willie Dalrymple. So I hope you enjoy that. I hope you've enjoyed this. We will be back soon.
关于历史他们一无所知，他们做得很好，他们是原型，对吧？乖乖女、荡妇、那种逆来顺受的妻子，他们绝对是那种几乎略带滑稽的原型，这也是为什么如果他拥有考古学会拥有的房产，完全就是德国人的经典原型。好的。对。非常感谢大家的收听。我们周四播出的下一集是威廉·达尔林普尔讲东印度公司。希望大家喜欢。希望你们喜欢这期节目。我们很快就会回来。
Thanks a lot. Bye-bye. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢。再见。再见。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。如需收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。